it was originally written set into a
forest location that we just do it again
every iteration of the script was based
on what locations we could eventually
fine or we knew we can secure but as we
watched yourself and the number of other
filmmakers we admired go through
Kickstarter with though we can raise a
little bit of money we can hire so we
could hire somebody to help shoot it we
can print some equipment so we went
along me we set a very small base just
twenty five hundred dollars we wanted to
raise which would have been probably a
couple light rentals in a camera rental
and we ended up right we ended up
raising just a little over seven
thousand dollars which was really
tremendous and we did it we rape we
broke our rogue our goal I think in
seven days and then we had another we
set a 30-day limits so we had the rest
of month just to just to bring some
extra funds so once we have that money
we were able to the bulk of the budget
actually went to the warehouse location
which is a great location downtown
reckon secretary bridge that was fifth
the budget was renting that for ten
hours yeah it's okay i was going to a
donation for people all over the country
that we zero contact with you and I
don't know how that whether it's between
Facebook and Twitter and just the
Kickstarter site but and I think just
banging people and just observe other
people's campaigns have an angel the
cabbage strategy for it where you know
when you first open up you're gonna have
a couple people who are close to you or
going to put a little money in first
just get started started and at the end
you know that you have somebody who can
come in and sweep in with some money in
case for the door now we weren't raised
in a ton of money so I'm not sure how
you're under nine dollars but for us
that certainly works sure to include had
one who who were so generous to us I
mean co-stars get a second or third
Thank You runs up and the great thing
about Kickstarter is it made us feel it
it emboldened us to actually go get
other actors and bring them in Marissa
Christopher and Serena and Ron verdad it
felt it just gave us it felt like a
little bit more cachet or it such as
Todd not shooting the bedroom pretending
we were doing something yeah that's my
ticket that DVD another movie yeah but
it just just just gave us a nice little
booze to be able to go out to other
actors and say they were doing this and
when you show up on said you know there
will be a set you know one of the crew
members that you end up getting on board
it was initially their first choice but
he became a muscle bay that helped Brian
this project from beginning to end it
was on the NRI Casey and here at L&T
before the thing that he just loves
filmmaking you know and he's a filming
herself and yet here we are tonight
first time seeing one of his works on
big screen you know myself just super
excited for Casey Casey you talk a
little bit about how you feel here
tonight first I gotta say I guess I'm
extremely honored to hear I didn't want
to do this my whole life but by the time
I was 18 I found a way to be a carpenter
and to have two guys who took a chance
on me because I had never done a short
a lot of music videos and I mostly my
face was an editing but my whole life of
one be a filmic and I didn't work on
shooting and it it dropped the way they
came in the the guy they had dropped out
and hey can you do it and I said yeah
I'm sure I love you but I can't shoot
tomorrow its my anniversary of you she's
probably I don't kill me it's our first
Hanover's because I can't do it but then
everything worked out to where within
three days we should be shot this film
and I you guys know when you're on set
there's there's nothing like the
creative enclosure to everybody brings
it's just could you have a better job I
mean is there I I spent a lot of my life
in dishes and corn concrete for giant
buildings that everyone needs to walk in
all the time and this is the best aim
thing there is my whole world there's
like this why why would you say yes you
know I'm sure a lot of folks without
like I would love to get a recognized
back there one of my projects why would
you say yes to this one why it is you i
purchased our salon to the top give me a
call shot me an email I talked a little
bit about it and said your script I love
to script that purpose of one view and
that's it if it's got those things and I
know better going serious and i miss
around i'm a big fan and be supported in
tiny skirt bill I'm not even the money I
was before what Brian's vision was and
we wanted to do and it was all there on
the page for our person Serena how did
how did you learn the project in NY why
did you ladies get well well I've gotta
talk her for many years I responded to
the script as well I have a friend of
mine that I used to work with she was in
Virginia now but she's married to any
detail and we had many conversations
when she was when she started dating him
and you know whether she's been very him
and how her like an 82 to sort of have
her husband go off on these missions and
then he may never go back so I wanted to
think that rolling kind of brain essence
of her into this arena um well Brian and
I were and then asking studio together
and he brought the project to me and
brought the script to me and i also just
responded to it I mean I read it it was
very moving and truthful and had a
message and just really wanted to be a
part of it did you think this when I
thought oh you've been involved with
this one early early days Europe did you
think this whatever did it I bought and
get made when I read first short version
not good p where he wasn't going to
happen it it became clear to us that we
need to simply make something first
instead of having ideal division
film which is kind of an impossible
thing to accomplish it first started out
so we basically
tell story movies two guys and see what
you can learn by making them and eat the
version that was up here tonight very
different from from the first part in
short we all send a blinder Mexico City
completely different set of tiger
thankfully that new idea of Jacob as a
character it was actually features group
from 2004 and it's a completely
different world I'm sonically different
worlds the same character you don't
really learn too much about him in the
feature its basic prior to the events in
this it's and learning why he's become
what he's become so over that it's come
and go I'm sure we've all had scripts
that we bring out and we put away and we
bring off put away and this was about a
year though I'm just honing this down as
a as a short I have a like a long
process where he has to kind of sit in
my head and come out and said my hair
but India ish ly they've been said the
different they had been sent to emit on
a mission to Latin America and I decided
I couldn't go to Latin America little
unfeasible evils are seven thousand
dollars and he has a long process but
it's the best of it it's the best when
you're patient with it because
eventually you'll find something that's
better than if you're not patient
you